good evening and thank you so much for
joining us tonight at 11 o'clock i'm
sasha loftis the rise in violence has
funeral directors and morticians
speaking out here in las vegas reminding
the community about the impact these
kinds of incidents have a march took
place this afternoon in the historic
west side of town honoring the lives
lost to violence madison kimbrough joins
us live this evening with more on their
message madison
we're here off of owens avenue it's
where the march took place earlier but
it's also where a homicide took place
just a couple days ago and organizers
say it's time for a change and it starts
here
i've watched this community evolve
and it's not getting any better it's
getting worse at this point the national
funeral directors and morticians
association of nevada coming together
sunday evening to get a message out stop
the violence and increase the peace
seems simple but according to metro las
vegas has seen a 67 percent increase in
murders across the valley compared to
last year community members particularly
in the historic west side district want
change we want to just encourage the
community to be aware of issues that
take place day in and day out where
young people older people are dying from
senseless violence and our goal was to
target here first at sunday's march
local funeral homes slowly processioned
through on owens avenue with empty
hearses families who had lost loved ones
to violence also carried signs and
posters with their family members
pictured emily dodd and her
granddaughter journey experienced their
own loss last year and say that having a
march like this brings them a sense of
security it brings strength to
myself as well as it allows
me to know that i'm not the only one
going through this to see that i'm also
not doing this alone and that kids my
age
are
going through the same thing i'm going
through
[Music]
and the plan is to have more political
figures involved in these marches to get
the message out they're hoping that
they'll have one or two more marches
coming up within next year reporting
live madison kimbrough live local now
matt